hola soy honor de khan academy en este
vídeo
veremos cómo configurar tus clases y dos
listas de lo primero que debes hacer es
iniciar sesión y verás tu panel de
control del tutor este es tu espacio
personal para todas las actividades de
maestría del panel de control del tutor
puedes navegar a tus clases ver tus
listas de alumnos y acceder a los
recursos para maestros
aquí puedes crear una nueva clase
recomendamos que configures clases
diferentes para cada periodo o grupo de
alumnos
si usas google classroom la forma más
rápida de organizar a tus alumnos es
importando tus clases si no usas google
classroom puedes crear una clase desde
cero lo siguiente es asignar un curso
desplázate a la parte inferior para ver
la lista completa de cursos disponibles
puedes escoger uno o varios cursos
muchos maestros utilizan algún curso del
año anterior como repaso para
remediación no te preocupes puedes
cambiar el nombre de tus cursos y tus
clases si cambias de parecer
lo siguiente es crear la lista de
alumnos para tu clase
nuevamente si usas google classroom
recomendamos que importen las listas los
alumnos también pueden ingresar a tu
clase usando un código recuerda que
todos los alumnos deben ingresar a khan
academy usando su correo electrónico si
tus alumnos son menores de 13 años y no
tienen cuentas de google pueden crearles
una cuenta en khan academy de forma
manual nosotros generamos los nombres de
usuarios y contraseñas puedes editar las
contraseñas de tus alumnos y podrás
descargar la lista de nombres de
usuarios y contraseñas como referencia
es posible que los alumnos olviden su
información así que asegúrate de
descargar y guardar una copia
para mantener tus listas de alumnos
actualizadas selecciona una clase y ve a
la pestaña lista de alumnos si un alumno
nuevo se une a tu clase selecciona el
botón agregar alumno y utiliza tu método
preferido para agregarlo si un alumno se
cambia a un período diferente selecciona
su nombre y luego haz clic en el enlace
agregar a clase
luego podrás usar el enlace eliminar
alumno para eliminarlo de la clase
original si un alumno ya no forma parte
de tus clases selecciona su nombre y haz
clic en la liga dejar de tutorial esto
eliminará al alumno de tus listas puedes
limpiar toda la lista de alumnos de tus
clases al final del año seleccionando a
todos los alumnos y haciendo clic en la
liga dejar del tutorial una alumna puede
cambiar su nombre en la página del
alumno seleccionando la caja de su
nombre en la parte superior
por eso pídele que siempre escriba su
nombre real para que puedas encontrarlo
más fácilmente en el monitoreo como
tutor puedes editar el nombre de
pantalla de tu alumno al poner la flecha
encima de su nombre y haciendo clic en
la liga editar el nombre de pantalla
ingresó un nombre nuevo
haz clic en guardar luego enter y listo
para otros cambios en tu clase ve a la
pestaña configuraciones aquí puedes
editar el nombre de tu clase cambiar la
materia eliminar la clase o hacer otros
cambios importantes para más información
visita khan academy punto o hereje
diagonal visual ces